Now Bruce, just look right into the camera lens right here...
...and tell us your name, your age, and where you were born.
My last name is Lee, Bruce Lee. I was born in San Francisco in 1940. I'm 24 right now.
And you worked in motion pictures in Hong Kong?
Yes, since I was around six years old.
And when did you leave Hong Kong?
1959, when I was 18.
And you went to college in the United States?
Yes.
And what did you study?
Philosophy.
Would you look right into the camera lens and explain the principle of the glass of water...
...as it applies to kung fu.
Well, kung fu, the best example would be a glass of water.
Why? Because water is the softest substance in the world,...
...but yet it can penetrate the hardest rock or anything, granite, you name it.
So, every kung fu man is trying to do that,...
...to be soft like water, and flexible and adapt itself to the opponent.
I see. What's the difference between a kung fu punch and a karate punch?
Well, the karate punch is like an iron bar, whang!
A kung fu punch is like an iron chain with an iron ball attached to the end, and it go whang!
And it hurts inside.
Show me once again, just a few movements there.
Well, kung fu can be practiced alone or with a partner.
Practicing alone may involve forms. Some imitate a crane, a monkey, a praying mantis.
This is a crane form.
Start off.
This is one of the movements involved.
Show us one more movement and then we'll be all through.
Okay, I'm glad to hear that.
They have the tiger...
...that starts like a tiger,...
...using claw to claw the face or the beak of the crane to the eyes.
These are some of the movements involved.
Thank you very much.